the Justice Department's investigation
into classified documents held to
President Joe Biden's private home and
former office CBS News has learned about
20 documents in total were discovered
dating back to Mr Biden's years as vice
president attorney general Merrick
Garland has appointed a special counsel
to investigate Mr Biden's handling of
those documents and this morning there's
growing concern the discovery could
become a political liability House
Republicans have launched their own
investigation and vowed to hold Mr Biden
and members of his administration's feet
to the fire cbs's Christina ruffini is
at the White House with the very late
it's Christina good morning good morning
Michelle well throughout the week West
Wing staffers and various other
Democratic officials have expressed
concern to CBS news about how the White
House rolled out this information and
why it took them so long to tell the
public
President Biden did not answer questions
about the investigation during meetings
Friday with the Japanese prime minister
or as he departed to spend the weekend
at his Wilmington home that home is one
of the location's special prosecutor
Robert Herr appointed Thursday by the
justice department will have to look
into as he investigates the president's
handling or mishandling of classified
material CBS News has learned the total
number of known classified documents
found is around 20 fewer than 10 were at
the Delaware residence in his garage and
a nearby room and by the way my
Corvette's in a lock garage okay so it's
not like you're sitting on the street
others including some marked top secret
were located at this Capitol Hill office
used by Mr Biden after his time as vice
president what I can tell you is that we
were not given a heads up I'm here today
to announce the appointment of Robert
Herr yesterday the White House said it
was not informed in advance of Attorney
General Merritt Garland's decision to
appoint a special counsel that is
something that we learned like like many
of you
watching the news but the White House is
also Under Fire for not disclosing the
initial Discovery when it was made in
November right before the critical
midterm election our CBS News colleague
Stephen Portnoy were you or any member
of your staff involved in the crafting
of the strategy as to when this
disclosure should be made in advance of
CBS News breaking the story on Monday no
Friday House Republicans announced
another investigation into the found
documents telling the Attorney General
the American people deserve transparency
and accountability they have no
accounting or inventory of what
classified documents they still possess
and why they even possess them to begin
with
now many of those same Democrats draw a
distinction between both the number of
Biden documents and the fact that his
team has been cooperating with the
National Archives and former president
Trump and the more than 300 documents
that were either recovered or seized
from Mar-A-Lago Jeff
Christina raffini thank you very much